arriving at an airport have you both got
your documentation
yes getting checked in
[Music]
making it onto the plane
things that have been fraught and
uncertain this summer
but at london's south end airport you
might notice something unexpected this
airport is very very quiet
passenger numbers here are down 95 on
three years ago airlines pulled out
during the pandemic and haven't returned
it might seem mad given the turmoil at
bigger airports the boss has offered to
help airlines to host flights at risk
we've reached out actually to to many of
the people who are going to be affected
by some of the the impacts i think the
issue is that it's just very late for
people so um we may be able to play i
mean candidly a minor role in it but a
minor role is a useful role if it's your
flight that's affected where we are is
we've got a hiatus situation this summer
it's not been great let's not kill
ourselves it's been far from great it
needs to be much better for next year
and i'm sure it will be
many would agree like those who
experienced this as demand boomed the
system buckled cancellations cues and
lost bags
things got so strained at heathrow a
customer caps now imposed
the fact that this airport is as quiet
as it is at precisely the same time that
other airports are making cancellations
is really an indication of just how
off-kilter this industry is
post-pandemic it was one of the hardest
hit sectors rebuilding was already a
huge challenge sustaining that new
customer demand and confidence will be
paramount the biggest process that we
have to follow is to ensure that we can
get you security clean the key cause is
a chronic lack of staff something
cully's working hard to address
he's an aviation recruiter and his job
has never been harder vacancies he says
have doubled and applicants well they've
halved too many let go during covert
they found better jobs with better terms
and conditions which then
enabled them to actually think actually
i don't want to work in the airport
environment no i don't want to work
shifts no more i've got some clients who
are coming to me crying saying i booked
in 10 people
no one turned up for interviews and that
is the reality
airports say they just didn't have
enough notice to reopen brexit 2 means
staff options are smaller
experts say it may all prompt an
industry reset the model of low cost no
longer sustainable we've always we've
always had a challenge of there being
more supply
than there is actual demand and airlines
actually creating artificial demand with
very low fares we'll see
either fewer airlines or we're going to
have to pay a more realistic price for
our airfares airports and airlines say
things are improving but passengers may
well expect better helena smith sky news
south end